I'm affected every single day I'm living
hell every minute of every day my mind
has the pain that I feel in my heart
hurts and I leave my family must be
heartbreaking to read oh yeah for Louise
Sears reading her brothers letters from
prisoners both agonizing and it seems
never-ending Ricky Sears was handed an
indeterminate sentence for his part in a
violent assault the judge set a minimum
term of three years thirteen years later
he's still in sight it's absolutely
heartbreaking and we are literally
living hell it's torture
we're told Ricky will be home you know
after this long next parole next parole
it's now being you know coming up for 13
years it's a struggle and it hurts
introduced in 2003 indeterminate or IPP
sentences were designed to protect the
public from those whose individual
offenses didn't warrant life sentences
but who were still believed to pose a
wider threat to the public
at its height more than six thousand
prisoners were serving IPP sentences but
the policy was deemed unjust and
scrapped in 2012 seven years on there
are still almost two and a half thousand
IPP prisoners 90% have served beyond
their original tariffs NIC Hardwick was
forced to quit as head of the parole
board in a row over the proposed release
of the most notorious IPP prisoner taxi
driver rapist John war boys a continuing
danger war boys would now be released
anytime soon but NIC Hardwick says the
vast majority of IPP prisoners are
low-risk and stuck in limbo to get out
you need to prove that you're no longer
a risk it's not the state that has to
prove you're dangerous you have to prove
you're safe and of course that's an
incredibly difficult thing to do if
you're in prison
prison reformers see a change in the law
is now urgently needed Parliament needs
to step in and finish the job that it
started doing in 2012 when it abolished
the sentence everybody serving the
sentence now needs a fixed date of
release from custody and they need a
fixed date when their license will come
to an end the Ministry of Justice says
even those an indeterminate sentences
can apply for release if it can convince
the parole board they are no longer a
threat but Louis Cyr says her brother
has lost hope that he can ever do that
it's an absolute struggle for him
there's no release date there's no
support there's no nothing I can't
really put into words how much strain is
put on the family it's kind of ripped us
apart even when an IPP prisoner is
finally released they remain on a life
license and many committee even the most
minor of infractions can find themselves
locked back up again Mark white Sky News